si le calme est revenu sur les grandes
places du kazakhstan la colère elle est
toujours aussi vive pour cet opposant
politique réfugie en france via thiès
dans ce cachot pour être honnête je ne
croyais pas que le régime pouvait
organiser des exécutions de masse et je
les mêmes dit je n'y croyais pas et j'ai
même exprimé ma position partout selon
laquelle ce n'est pas réaliste parce que
s'ils le font ils soufflent
arabia zone a été ministre et banquier
au kazakhstan avant de fuir son pays il
a fondé un parti d'opposition mobilisés
surtout depuis l'étranger aujourd'hui
ils accusent le régime kazakh de
sous-estimer grossièrement le nombre de
morts tombés sous les balles des forces
de l'ordre depuis une semaine
nous pensons qu'il y ait en fait plus
d'un millier de victimes et les
autorités disent qu'il y a plus d'un
millier de blessés ce qui signifie
qu'elle sous-estiment au moins les
données à plusieurs reprises nous
considérons qu'il s'agit simplement d'un
massacre il en veut pour preuve les
dizaines de vidéos qui circulent sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui lui sont envoyées
directement on y voit des sacs
mortuaires qui défilent innombrables
dans les morgues de deux des hôpitaux
d'almac et la capitale économique
la ville a été l'épicentre de la colère
de ses concitoyens qui se sont révoltés
parfois violemment contre la hausse des
prix de l'essence
et c'est un mouvement qui va bien au
delà et qui n'a pas dit son dernier mot
le duo japonais les gens ont compris ce
que nous pouvions faire et ce n'est que
grâce à l'intervention de poutine que la
situation a changé nous n'attendons que
l'aide internationale pour amener
poutine a quitté le kazakhstan ensuite
une nouvelle phase de résistance
président du kazakhstan kassim tokayev
affirme que son pays a déjoué une
tentative de coup d'état sans pour
autant en apporter la preuve en
visioconférence avec le président russe
qui a dépêché deux mille soldats pour
soutenir le gouvernement kazakh il a
déclaré que les événements sanglants de
la semaine dernière avaient été
orchestrés depuis l'étranger
laissons personne déstabiliser la
situation chez nous et mettre en oeuvre
des scénarios de révolutions colorées a
dit aujourd'hui vladimir poutine en
référence aux différentes révolutions
qui ont secoué la région au début des
années 2000 poutine entretien
poutine veut construire un prototype de
l'union soviétique conquérir
progressivement de différentes manières
pour manipuler comme dans le cas du
kazakhstan il veut prendre le contrôle
de toutes les centrales et construire
une union soviétique analogues il veut
des troupes et que tout soit sous son
contrôle mais cela n'arrivera pas notre
peuple résistera et ce sera une
résistance très sérieuses et beaucoup de
personnes se prononceront en disant que
nous allons nous battre le début du vote
il appelle la communauté internationale
à imposer des sanctions sévères et sans
complaisance dit il pour prévenir de
nouveaux bains de sang lui se dit prêt à
devenir premier ministre d'un
gouvernement provisoire sans président
mais il ne peut pas retourner au
kazakhstan en 2017 cet ancien oligarque
a été condamné en son absence à 20 en
prison dans une affaire de détournement
de fonds alors qu'il dirigeait la banque
bta en lui accordant l'asile la justice
française a estimé que ce sont des
accusations dont le mobile est purement
politique
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada paris